herr professor dittmann also inwiefern
droht da auch eine kritische menge lage
in europa im winter wenn jetzt
tatsächlich eben der deutsche größere
angst hat zu frieren während in polen
die gasspeicher zum beispiel schon jetzt
fast voll sind und am ende man in polen
sagt naja bei euch in deutschland wollen
nichts abgeben von unserem gas
ja verteilen war in der eu ja schon
immer ein problem fingen 2015/16 bei den
flüchtlingen an und geht jetzt sozusagen
beim gras weiter aber es muss ganz klar
konstatiert werden dass hier die
osteuropäischen partner der eu das
baltikum polen insbesondere lange
gewarnt hatten vor dieser ausgebauten
abhängigkeit von russischem gas über
nord stream 1 und 2 vor allen dingen und
dann hat man in mitteleuropa in
deutschland insbesondere diese wandten
stimme nicht so ernst genommen hat
gesagt nee das könnte nicht im krieg
eingesetzt werden es geht hier
eigentlich um billiges gas primär es ist
ein bis kurz vor ausbruch des krieges
hieß es ja noch nord stream 2 hätte
überhaupt nichts mit dem krieg zu tun
und ähnliches jetzt sind wir alle eines
besseren belehrt worden nicht nur
sachlich sondern auch in hinsicht darauf
dass man warnende stimmen die ist ja
vorher gab also niemand kann heute sagen
das hätte man vorher nicht gewusst die
ist vorher aus dem wald gegangen aus
polen gab ernst zu nehmen aber das ist
natürlich ein jetzt blick zurück wenn
wir den blick nach vorne richten also in
diesem schlamassel sitzen ja jetzt alle
fast alle vielleicht die osteuropäischen
eu partner etwas weniger als der westen
europas aber im winter spätestens
könnten ja dann alle im gleichen
schlamassel sitzen wenn man jetzt auf
den eu-notfallplan der heute in brüssel
vorgestellt werden soll schaut dann ist
das wort solidarität das haupt
schlagwort wie viel solidarität sie als
konfliktforscher an sie auch die frage
wie viel solidarität erwarten sie denn
in der eu ist klar dass wenn einzelne
staaten im winter probleme bekommen dass
dann andere aus der eu helfen werden
oder ist das überhaupt nicht sicher doch
das ist relativ sicher natürlich geht
das nicht reibungslos aber ich setze
hier darauf dass das funktionieren wird
denn andere sind hier auch schon
entsprechend in der vorratshaltung
weiter als deutschland insbesondere ist
polen weiter als wir weil es rechtzeitig
gas gesetzt hat und es gibt noch eine
ganze war ja noch eine ganze palette von
möglichkeiten so dass man von zwei
dingen eigentlich zuversichtlich
ausgehen kann dass sich die speicher
weiter füllen werden bis zum winter aber
auch davon dass genau auf diese
uneinigkeit der bauer die sie ansprachen
putin natürlich setzt und deshalb die
prognosen auch in russischer propaganda
jetzt schon auf den winter hinweisen und
genau darauf setzen dass hier
uneinigkeit entstehen könnte und dann
wäre das ein einfallstor für die politik
und für eine sanktionierung von welchem
status quo in der ukraine noch immer
sieht man dass er so gas ist ja der eine
mangel und der andere mangel meine damen
und herren sind derzeit natürlich viele
lebensmittel und vor allem der weizen
kommt eben normalerweise aus der ukraine
und der zeit eben nicht
herr professor tut man inwiefern ist das
was wir da eben dem beitrag gesehen
haben der weizen die lieferung nach
europa aber das schließt sich der kreis
auch zum beginn der sendung das war ja
auch gestern diskussion in teheran
der weizen korridor eben in den osten
nach russland für russland inwiefern ist
dass das nächste konfliktpotenzial oder
wir sind schon mittendrin wir sind in
der tat mitten drin denn die spannende
frage ist ja ob es gelingen wird ein
korridor zu öffnen für die ausfuhr der
weizenernte vom letzten jahr zusammen
machen die russischen und den
ukrainischen
weizenproduktion etwa 28 prozent der
weltweiten produktion aus das ist schon
eine menge und es gibt einige ländern
durchaus nicht alle im globalen süden
aber einige die ganz speziell auf den
weizen aus der ukraine angewiesen sind
und das sind traditionelle hunger länder
und dort genau in einige davon in afrika
andere in der region mittlerer osten da
gibt es dann preissteigerungen also
eigentlich ist das ein instrument an dem
auch putin drehen kann wenn das
gesamtziel ist andere systeme zu
destabilisieren dabei kommt es vor allen
dingen auf solche länder an die
potentiellen prowestlich sind also ein
aufstand in einem westlichen land pro
westlich ausgerichteten land der
mena-region dass wir für putin super und
wenn man damals ein exporte verhindern
kann dann wäre das ein wichtiges
instrument aber hier kommt auch mit in
die rolle dass putin im moment dabei ist
global an seinem image zu schrauben er
hat ja mehr oder weniger starke
unterstützung also mehr als neutralität
starke unterstützung aus ländern des
globalen südens erfahren und wenn er
sich jetzt als jemand darstellen kann
mit erdogan es unterstützung und der
hungersnöte verhindert der weizenexport
wieder möglich macht dann wird das
weitere gute stimmung im globalen süden
bringen können also solange wird noch
damit gespielt auch mit menschen leben
mit hungertoten gespielt mit preisen
gespielt bis dann das potenzielle der
potenzielle profit aus dieser politik am
größten geworden ist
professor andreas dittmann geograf von
der universität in gießen
konfliktforscher vielen danke ihnen sehr
spannend diese ganzen einordnungen auch
der geopolitischen lage verkennen